more than 25 years after the original
film debut
the jurassic park franchise continues to
thrill fans around the world
here's a look back at the original
trilogy and a whole bunch of behind the
scenes information
that not even hardcore fans know about
the making of these blockbuster films
tracking the inspiration for jurassic
park leads to spielberg's love of
dinosaurs as a child
he recalled to entertainment weekly i
was more interested
in the dinosaurs in king kong than i was
in king kong himself
i thought the t-rex was one of the most
awesome dinosaurs of the fossil record
in the late 1980s spielberg met author
and screenwriter michael crichton
a harvard medical school graduate whose
novels such as the andromeda strain
the terminal man and congo among others
often hinge on problems of a scientific
nature
as the two developed a script based on
crichton's time as a medical resident
a project that would later become the tv
series er
crichton mentioned another idea of his a
novel about dinosaurs brought to life
through discovered samples of dna
considering the existence of a real-life
gene editing technology called crispr
that was later unveiled in 2012
the concept crichton was talking about
was certainly ahead of its time
the premise instantly piqued spielberg's
interest and before crichton had even
finished the novel
universal studios paid the author 2
million dollars for the film rights and
a first draft of the screenplay
screenwriter david kepp whose credits
include death becomes her
mission impossible and spider-man later
came on board
he streamlined the science and with
spielberg came up with the animated mr
dna to explain how the fictional theme
park spawned dinosaurs in a lab
a dna strand like me is a blueprint for
building a living thing in jurassic park
wealthy businessman john hammond invites
paleontologist dr
alan grant played by sam neal
paleobotanist dr ellie sadler
played by laura dern and jeff goldblum's
mathematician dr ian malcolm to the
fictional island
of isla nublar off costa rica to tour
his live
dinosaur theme park and certify that
it's safe for the public
spielberg offered harrison ford the role
of grant but ford turned it down
paving the way for neil who according to
an interview with entertainment weekly
in 2013
quote hadn't read the book knew nothing
about it hadn't heard anything about it
laura dern said yes in part because
nicholas cage who had just wrapped wild
at heart with her
encouraged her to do it jim carrey gave
a terrific audition for the ever
quotable dr malcolm according to casting
director janet herschensen
the jeff goldblum ended up winning out
over him as for hammond
crichton initially liked sean connery
whom crichton directed in 1978's the
great train robbery based on his 1975
novel
however spielberg liked attenborough's
ambivalence
the director said in an interview with
empire i was much more interested in
portraying hammond
as a cross between walt disney and ross
perrault adam burl sort of keeps you off
balance
second guessing what his motives are
hawaii
specifically the gorgeous island of
kauai hosted part of the production of
the first jurassic park
locations that were used include manuahi
opuna falls where the helicopter lands
with hammond and his guests
and the puoca ele reservoir where the
actors gaped at the roaming
brachiosaurus that the special effects
team added later
in the film a tropical storm strikes the
island ramping up the suspense as the
power fails
in real life the production faced
hurricane iniki which made landfall at
kauai in september 1992
with winds over 140 miles per hour
spielberg turned on the hotel
tv early one morning to see the weather
report complete with
quote the icon of a cyclonic hurricane
moving directly towards us
it was like a movie the cast and crew
huddled in a hotel ballroom for safety
although some shot footage of the
approaching storm ended up in the final
film
as wayne knight recalled the av club
producer kathleen kennedy got a lot of
people off the island and on to army
transports right before the hurricane
hit
but it exfoliated the entire island it
was really bad
he's not wrong more than 1 400 houses
were destroyed when the hurricane struck
land
and six people died bringing jurassic
park's dinosaurs to life took a
multifaceted approach that netted the
film three academy awards for its visual
effects sound
and sound effects editing legendary
creature designer and special effects
creator stan winston
known for his work on aliens terminator
2 and many other projects
created large form models of dinosaurs
including one of the tyrannosaurus rex
that was nearly 20 feet tall jeff
goldblum recalled to entertainment
weekly
i used to be enthralled with dinosaurs
like a lot of kids
so cut to me in hawaii coming on the set
and seeing that thing
already fully there and the puppeteers
one working the eyes
one doing the breathing for all the
world it was a live dinosaur sitting
there
amazing stop-motion artist phil tippett
known for his work on robocop
animated miniatures of winston's designs
for some of the action sequences
he even sent the animators to mime
classes to help make the dinosaur's
movements more fluid
the production also used
computer-generated dinosaurs notably
during the galamia stampede
when spielberg asked tippett how he felt
after seeing the cg footage of the
stampede
tippett recalled saying i think i'm
extinct he said
that's a great line i'm putting that in
the movie so what are you thinking
we're out of a job don't you mean
extinct as for the dinosaurs snorts
roars and other sounds sound designer
gary rydstrom said he wanted to keep the
creature effects sounding organic
so he used noises from real animals
about 20 or 30 animal sounds alone for
the raptors
including a combination of walrus and
dolphin for the main attack screen
one reason for jurassic park's enduring
appeal is the cast's genuine awe
even when they weren't sure how the
final footage would look durn remembered
how she and neil
couldn't help but hug the lifelike
triceratops puppet
she recalled to entertainment weekly we
were both freaking out
and like sam does in the movie we did
lay ourselves over the belly and
feel the belly moving in and out she
also added that she forced the
puppeteers to let her see how the
high-tech illusion worked
when spielberg asked neil to imagine how
he feel upon seeing grazing dinosaurs
the actor said he thought he'd faint he
told entertainment weekly quote
that's why my knees go in the shot yet
for all its grand scale
spielberg saw the film as more than a
monster mash he told empire
this film is more like 10 little indians
than it is godzilla attacking tokyo
there's a presumption in the genre that
the more invasive the people in an
environment
are the more ill-equipped they are to
survive it and the more the audience
feels they deserve what's coming
certainly crichton who wrote and
directed 1973's west world about another
theme park gone awry
liked to explore technology's perils but
the film can also be read as a metaphor
for reproductive fears and patriarchal
control
thanks to geneticist dr henry wu
asserting that the park's animals are
engineered to be female
how do you know they're all female
somebody got in the park and
pull up the dinosaur skirts we control
their chromosome
because of jurassic park's popularity
spielberg was happy to sign up for a
sequel
for 1997's the lost world jurassic park
the director and returning screenwriter
kepp
adapted only pieces of crichton's 1995
novel the lost world
which itself took its title from sir
arthur conan doyle's 1912 dinosaur tale
the story this time around involved
hammond hiring dr malcolm to join an
expedition of dinosaur advocates at a
second island
isla sorna where his company had
conducted its research in secret
a storm has left the island's creatures
running wild something people discover
after a vacationing family stops there
for a picnic and some of the local
wildlife
eyeballs their daughter as a snack
malcolm agrees to go along after
learning his paleontologist girlfriend
sarah harding is already there along
with a cadre of dinosaur hunters
including pete possilthwaite's roland
tembo the sequel weaves in homages to
classic films and monster movies
including the big game plot of 1962's
hatari
and 1961's gorgo in which a prehistoric
monster
wrecks london to retrieve her baby just
like the mama t-rex during the lost
world climax rampages through san diego
in pursuit of her child planning the
lost world jurassic park took at least
two years including designing the action
set pieces
and building the creatures although the
film used more cgi
stan winston returned to develop the
animatronics to map out the logistics of
the complex
action sequences the crew used almost 1
500 storyboards spielberg also trusted
cinematographer januz kaminsky
who won an academy award for his work on
spielberg's oscar-winning 1993 film
schindler's list
to create a darker look for this film
compared to the original as kaminsky has
been quoted as saying
jurassic park was very much like an
amusement park ride the images were
brighter more colorful and more friendly
this film is much more moody and violent
kaminsky also noted that he found
inspiration for the lost world in films
such as 1982's blade runner
1979's alien 1954's godzilla
in 1933's king kong the lost world
jurassic park earned about 618 million
dollars worldwide on an estimated budget
of 73 million dollars
a box office hit if a mixed bag for
critics who found the characterization
lacking
and the story beats perfunctory looking
back on his career in 2016
spielberg told the new york times that
the lost world was an example of his
enthusiasm getting the better of it
he explained my sequels aren't as good
as my originals because i go on to every
sequel i've made and i'm too confident
this movie made a gazillion dollars
which justifies the sequel
so i come in like it's going to be a
slam dunk and i wind up making an
inferior movie to the one before
i'm talking about the lost world in
jurassic park
for 2001's jurassic park iii spielberg
remained as an executive producer but
handed directing duties to joe johnston
he'd worked with spielberg as a visual
effects artist on raiders of the lost
ark before directing 1989's honey i
shrunk the kids
1991's the rocketeer in 1995's jumanji
johnston had been eager to work on a
sequel ever since jurassic park took off
sam neil liked johnston's enthusiasm and
quote sheer sense of mischief
the actor told the bbc he was excited to
return to the franchise
saying i wasn't quite happy with what
i'd done with the character in the first
film
i was so over awed by spielberg i think
i didn't quite look after my guy as well
as i might have
getting alan back to the island proved
problematic at first though
the story went through several drafts
including one with teenagers stranded on
isla sorna the island from the lost
world
the johnston said quote read like a bad
episode of friends
jurassic park could happen
the filmmakers also scrapped another
version that had been planned and
storyboarded with 18 million dollars
already spent about five weeks before
filming began cap suggested keeping the
story simple
and the script credited to peter buckman
alexander payne and jim taylor
ultimately had an estranged couple
played by william h macy and tia leone
hiring alan to help rescue their son
who'd become stranded on isla sorna
after parasailing nearby
even with an estimated budget of 93
million dollars jurassic park 3 had a
rough start because of the unfinished
script
johnson later told entertainment weekly
we didn't have an ending that we liked
the first time we were there
leone agreed and went even further with
her assessment saying
we just had the ending missing joe is
being graceful
we started in hawaii with no ending the
middle a little up in the air
and the beginning uh pretty solid
the constant revisions proved stressful
with macy telling tv guide
the script has been evolving and being
rewritten as we go
and what you want to say is who launched
a 100 million dollar ship without a
rudder and who's getting fired for this
it's a bad idea johnston later chalked
up macy's comments to being interviewed
on a bad day
noting that macy had otherwise been a
trooper who quote never refused to do
anything
regardless the director acknowledged in
star dog magazine that the 16 or so
weeks of shooting were grueling
with the actors being quote never
comfortable they were always wet they
were always in mud
they were hanging in trees they were
underwater they were running
falling getting stepped on and getting
trapped in places
for one sequence in which the crew
tumbled the cast around in what would be
the fuselage of a crashed plane
johnston said i don't know how the
actors got out without broken arms and
amputations
laura dern also returned to jurassic
park 3 as ellie sattler but with her
character being married
and mom to a young son she missed out on
the stunt work
ellie was still close friends with alan
though and provided a helping hand from
afar in the last act
according to johnston all of her
material was shot over the course of a
single day
just as with the two films the special
effects crew didn't disappoint
with roughly 400 shots involving cgi
some of those adding
upper bodies to the animatronic feet of
winston's designs
the artists were determined to show
dinosaurs that audiences hadn't seen
before
such as ankylosaurus pteranodons and
erect avery
and the spinosaurus that last one was
included on the suggestion of
paleontologist and consultant jack
horner
who described the creature as quote a
massive carnivore with the snout of a
crocodile
a back fan resembling that of a
dimetrodon and the ferociousness of the
tyrannosaurus
upon its release the film earned about
365 million dollars worldwide
along with the high of a bmi film music
award for composers don davis and john
williams
and the low of a razzie award nomination
for worst remake or sequel
regardless when macy looked back on the
whole experience in 2018 he called it
beyond thrilling
in spite of harrowing moments like being
in a harness chained to a crane about 35
feet in the air
as he put it i bested the spinosaurus
and not many people can say they've done
that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you